hey Steve here to inform you that
eighty-five percent of college graduates
are moving back in with her parents
that's Michael he's one of the eighty
five percenters let's see what's going
on with him
hey hey you hey hey hey hey Dad Michael
welcome home son yeah what happened to
my room Rob namaste how's it go mr. feet
welcome dog Oh guys you're letting the
energy out whoo I'll get it dad what
happened to my room i transformed it to
what into a thinking room huh all the
material things had to go away to the
basement your stuffs in the basement
you're living in the basement now
thinking room yeah it's where hey comes
to thing pretty cool right what's this
reminds you of me right except I
wouldn't wear these pants those are
goofy that's just stupid but I did this
photoshop one class adult night class
thing but I told your mother I was going
out drinking so if it comes up okay
don't be a grumper sit on guys fatherly
advice time sit down you to rub right
here in the middle of the space your
time is now now you're young go out gets
good gal hit 20 gals right by a leather
jacket pop that collar find a lamppost
lean yourself into it hey girls what's
going on of the walk right go
catting around
yeah that's right got together with your
mom getting around I got married too
young variety of the spice of life so
make sure I have that my spice rack is
like a salt shaker bone dry yeah and you
don't want that salt spilling into your
rule way sorry hey Michael Sam your mom
come on hi sweetie am i living in the
basement you're living in the basement
Cheers in here joking around sure did
with my lady ears well here's your
thinking tea oh good character all there
sweetie it is real hot uh-huh so I'm
living in the basement you're living in
the basement I gotta get my own place
god I tried to tell you that hmm good
please I put half a little bit yeah
whose bones dry now huh well it looks
like Michaels gonna be sticking around
here for a while huh it's likely be good
he's way to get rough like really really
rough do to you still living at home
with your parents we're here to help
into the Comedy Central growing up and
getting out contest you could win rent
for a year presented by KFC original
recipe bites bite-sized chicken is all
grown up